but if you think about the U.S economy
in any day it's a consumer-driven
economy and if we see our consumers even
for the first weeks three weeks of
October they're now spending still nine
percent plus over what they spent last
year which is cons you know which is one
and a half times the two times the rate
they're spending pre-pandemic and so
that's a good thing now ahead of them
you know we've got the feds raising
rates and slowing down the economy and
that's what they have to do which means
housing is tipping over in price that's
supposed to happen used cars price to
flatten out that's supposed to happen so
the fed's trying to slow down the
economy but frankly working against them
is consumers are spending money they
have more money in their accounts and
that account balances are holding even
though it went up after the you know
with the pandemic stimulus payments it
basically held on and then they're all
employed unemployment rate's very low
the new claims was very low again last
week and then you know in the end of the
day they have good credit statistics and
have the ability to borrow so that's
good news it makes the fed's job harder
but right now in the U.S economy that's
good news for the world Frank because
the U.S consumes and spends money and
buys things all of which will help the
world get through this tough time as we
get the economies reoriented so so let's
talk about uh outside of the US and you
said a tough time there is is a tough
time how you would predict the outlook
for for Europe over the next year or so
considering what's going on in Europe
and at you know the war in Ukraine is is
a horrible thing for the people involved
Etc but also it's preoccupying for the
economy the energy crisis around that
those are all you know things which need
to straighten out the the Constitutional
crisis in various countries you know
getting new leadership in place and
getting a common view for the Europeans
of how they're going to attack the
energy crisis and other things those are
all important things critically
important things so that all has a drag
on the economy Energy prices being up
shutting down factories those are very
tough things to get through and you know
we hope that we'll see that mitigate as
as we go through 23 and on top of that
we've got to get interest rates back and
slow down inflation and inflations in
Europe and inflations in the U.S and the
jobs of the central banks were to flood
to Zone during the time of Crisis and
the pandemic but now they've got to back
off and let the economy rebalance and
it's a tough time to do that given the
circumstances around around these
economies in in the UK in recent weeks
I'm sure you saw the volatility in the
bond market and the particular issue of
ldis and too much leverage in certain
individual Pension funds when you saw
that did it did it remind you of 2008
and make you feel like there could be
other Gremlins hiding out there that
could trigger another financial crisis
we always look for you know if you think
about the The Princess and the P analogy
under all those mattresses you're always
looking for that P to figure out where
the risk is and where the risk gets
bottled up and and you saw some that
come out when you had a particularly
strong movement in in the guilt uh in
the bonds in in the UK but you know the
market now it loves stability they they
like no change or little change or
predictable change and you know you're
seeing it settle back down given given
the circumstances of the last few weeks
but you know that was interesting we
looked around and said where else could
this infect uh the economy but the good
news is the banking systems across the
world are in pretty good shape the
consumers are in pretty good shape
unemployment's been low and you know the
pandemic was a horrible thing for
everybody to go through in the world but
on the other hand of it we're still
recovering out that in the economic
activities still picking up to match
that and so we've got some other issues
ahead of us but you know that's good
news and that provides a little bit of
wind into sales as you said things have
calmed down a little bit in the UK they
picked up in the weeks between the mini
budget and today a new prime minister in
place in Rishi sunak how important is it
for the UK to now have a period of
political stability
I I think the UK is one of the leading
economies and leading countries in the
world and as a Bastion of stability and
in general sense and so stability in any
country is good stability we've got to
go through a midterm election the U.S
we've got to get to the other side of
that and the stability can settle in
you've had the changes in Italy and
you've got the elections in in Brazil
and stuff so there's a lot of change
that goes on but the key is to get it
stabilized and get through the period so
people can settle down and be more
predictable and I think you'll see that
take place in some of these economies as
these elections take place and we get to
the other side of them so we always say
our company's been around it's not a big
deal in the case of the UK but we've
been around since you know for 230 plus
years we've been through a lot of
Elections and our job is just to manage
through them and so we don't get too
wound up about any one of them it's
always something in the moment but it's
a population's job to elect their
officials and our job to manage our
company given those elections well it's
reassuring to have uh Brian is the
biggest retail bank in America with with
uh multiple thousand employees here in
the UK most of which in London the
volatility of the last few months hasn't
changed your view on whether to keep
those people here
it's a great place for people to work
you know we've done a lot on the brexit
move which is seems like ancient history
now given all the things that happened
since then but you know we've resettled
our our population of employees so our
employee base is a great set of
teammates in London I'm going to see
them later this week and they do a great
job for us and we expected we're
committed to the country and we'll
continue to those teammates and continue
to build out given the circumstances the
markets and what we can do uh and and
Rishi sunak himself uh obviously was
Finance Minister but before being Prime
Ministers of today have you ever come
across him personally what's your view
of him I I met him at the some of the
usual events that uh CEOs of large Banks
meet uh Finance ministers and uh you
know so if if it turns out it's all
official today which I haven't caught up
to the latest stuff you know good luck
and we'll do our job to support him as
we did our job to support the past PMS
in that country and other countries
around the world uh stepping back a
little bit from the craziness and the
volatility obviously one of only one of
the the various factors that that led to
to Liz truss's downfall was over
promising I I think it's fair to say on
on tax cuts one of that was on corporate
taxes would a lower corporate tax rate
all else equal in the long term in the
UK be something that that from Bank
America's perspective would be a good
thing governments have to get a balance
between taxation of Corporations
individuals and what they spend the
money on and that's a long-term problem
for all governments so the UK
government's no different from the U.S
government or from the Canadian
government for any other government so I
think getting that tax policy tax policy
right getting those uh levels right and
you saw that with some of the work
that's being done around these
agreements around minimum tax rates the
world we don't people shouldn't be
bidding for people's business on tax
rates because ultimately that leads to
things which get a little out of skew so
I think the key is to have a consistent
rate where people can invest across long
periods of times that's fair to the
companies and fair to the people they
employ and fair the business they
generate and tax revenues they generate
and then also fair to the citizens so
the governments can do what they need to
do and I you know I think those things
settled over time they go up and they go
down and you know we we don't live or
die by our tax rate we live die by
having great customers doing great
things with them generate a lot of
Revenue keep expenses and check do you
know a lot a lot of pre-tax income and
then we'll figure out what the taxing
authorities do but doesn't it's good
it's always good if you're paying taxes
like we pay a lot of taxes is it good to
be lower sure but on the other hand we
have we realize the company that the
need for tax dollars to help governments
do the work they need to do from you
know making sure their citizens have a
good Standard Life investing in future
infrastructure company the country
investing in you know the transition of
energy investing and Roads and and
things so that people can get to work
and transportation systems and Welfare
and and food and that's all incredibly
important thing so we're balanced about
that it's not we don't turn it off or
turn on a decision based on a tax rate
in the country unless it's way out of
line and Brian I mean clearly what one
outcome one consequence of recent months
has been a much weaker Euro and a much
weaker pound relative to the US dollar
could we expect U.S companies to be
looking uh to buy some some companies
across Europe and the UK and in the year
ahead longer term when the market
settles down especially for the private
Equity firms and the debt side of it in
other words there's predictability get
debt done in the market I think you'll
see you'll see back up so the backlogs
are huge frankly there's a lot of
conversations going on a lot of deals in
the pipeline but you just need stability
in the market and frankly you need
people to settle in the prices they're
trading at today versus what they may
have been trading at at a time when the
market was a lot higher to just get used
to sellers have to get used to their
price and get used to premiums that
might be available to them you have to
have debt predictability so you get the
deals financed and and frankly you have
to have some view of the future it's
hard to invest into a recession and and
you know our economists and most
economists around the world predict
recessions in various economies over the
next 12 to 18 months and so it's hard to
invest into that and that's why people
are sort of waiting it out right now